thank you for the introduction
and hello everyone first i would like to
thank the organizers
for giving me this opportunity to
present today
polygenic risk scores have recently
shown a lot of promise
in in a way as a way of predicting risk
for complex traits based on weighted
averages of the individual risk alleles
clinically prs scores have begun to be
used
for risk stratified genetic screening
basically deciding
on who needs to get genetic screening
for a particular disease
it also is helping refining the
individual risk assessment
which helps guide the kind of risk
reduction interventions
and that can be taken for example in the
clinic
um it it is helping for it is helping to
decide on the
on the tailoring of the therapy as well
as
changes in the lifestyle and environment
for example
it also is is helping predict
health outcomes which is which is
beginning to be used in complex diseases
like breast cancer
prostate cancer and diabetes while
polygenic
scores is is showing a lot of promise
there are a few challenges as you know
polygenic scores are very dependent on
the availability of very good quality
jos summary statistics
on from a lot of samples across a lot of
populations
we need good effect size and frequency
calculations
uh for the for the different different
predictions
one of the problems that we have been
running into is the generalizability of
these
of these risk predictions across
multiple populations
uh alicia martin and mark daley recently
showed
very nicely in in nature genetics
publications
where they looked at the accuracy of
prediction of prs across
european populations uh for 17
quantitative traits across five
different populations in the uk biobank
as you can see on in the figure on the
right the prediction works
really well for european populations but
for
the rest of the uh for the other
ancestry populations it is kind of
still a work in progress if you will
that brings us to the to the million
veteran program the million veteran
programs was initiated in 2011
by the va as a as a way to
to explore uh how genes lifestyles and
exposure affect health
and illness we have we collect
as part of the million veteran program
we collect biospecimens that are then
linked to the ehr
and self-reported and other health data
to give you a glance of what we have
done so far the mvp has collected over
828 000
samples we we we collect uh we
the collection sites are all across the
the united states
uh we have roughly about 60 61 rowing
rowing collection sites um that that
moves from
from station to station um
depending on on the interest shown by
the veterans to the mailers that we sent
about the mvp program
so to give you an overview of the mvp
data universe
from the mvp participants we collect
self-reported surveys
we essentially have two types of surveys
that we send out
one is a short five pager that gives
us questions about their health
in general and then we send out a much
longer 15 page surveys that that is more
of a lifestyle survey
we collect uh 10 ml blood as a biosample
from each of the participants when they
when they um when they sign their hipaa
and consent
and from these biosamples we generate
multiple molecular
data that that that can then be um
integrated with clinical data that we
get from the emr
from the va the cdw the corporate data
warehouse that sort of abstracts all the
all the clinical data from the emr
system so this provides
a an opportunity to integrate
longitudinal
clinical data with their molecular data
we also get data from other sources
including medicare
various disease registries national debt
index etc
so how do we do bio banking in mvp
the recruitment to mvp is basically an
all-comers
the inclusion criteria criteria is that
you have to be a veteran
and user of the va healthcare system and
there is no
no exclusion criteria so to speak of
we collect um 10 ml of blood in an edta
vacutainer at the
time of recruitment and these blood
samples are shipped overnight on ice
packs to the central repository in
boston most samples arrive
in 24 to 48 hours accessioning is done
into the lab's limb system without any
clinical identifiers
we save multiple aliquots of plasma
buffy codes and
an aliquot of of the buffy coat is then
made into dna which is then sent out for
uh molecular molecular analysis
we take care not to to have any sorting
biases and that's why
not having any clinical identifiers in
the lymph system
um helps because this is not we are not
collecting
it's not a case control study or we are
not collecting any disease specific so
it's an all comers
and and for the labs it is a sample
and that's it so to start to look at the
sort of the genomic um
analysis we first developed an mvp
genotyping array we developed this with
the help of
um affymetrix or thermofisher
uh on the axiom platform we use the
um the axiom biobank as sort of the
backbone onto which we added about 100k
custom
snips mainly the snips that are
clinically relevant over the next
few slides um i'll just go through very
briefly you know the kind of
design decisions that we took when we
built the mvp
custom array as you can see the backbone
has the
the axiom biobank content which includes
pharmacogenics
genetics exome grid loss of function g
was
um coverage um snips etc
on the custom content we we included a
lot of
a lot of clinically relevant snips um
including you know
sort of disease diagnostic or prognostic
disease relevant snips
including ras we also uh include a lot
of
hra hla and kir region snips with the
idea of being able to to see if we can
find map these regions um
better we also used uh increased sort of
the
you know have tax names that allows us
to increase the
the imputation quality in different
ethnicities
in terms of the clinical relevance of
the mvp
array this is an example where we are
looking at
the 10 top 10 acmg genes and how
the number of snips that have been used
on the microarray
to cover them we pretty much have
all the the entire acmg list is probed
on this array
we also um you as i said earlier that we
we have been um using typing a lot of
snips that are sort of
important for disease groups and here's
a list of
examples of the research areas and the
diseases that
that have been probed by these markers
so this is an overview of the sample and
data processing
workflow in mvp so we start with sample
collection
we do the data extraction in our
biorepository and we send it out for
genotyping
since mvp is continuing to
enroll participants and the analysis is
done over a longer period of time we pay
particular attention to how batching is
done
so we make sure that the the samples
that are collected together
are acid together um on on
on the axiom platform um we with
thermofisher we have developed
a a lot of um advanced
uh uh qc uh methods including
plate normalizations uh sample quality
control
sample and marker quality controls and
also
methods to sort of minimize batch
effects
we do multiple data quality control
assessments
and then we also generate sort of
secondary data in terms of relatedness
genetic ancestry
etc and we validate the sample uh the
data
before using you know height as a as an
example of ajiwas
before before making the data available
for analysis
as i mentioned earlier the
the mvp array has a lot of low frequency
alleles
because they are clinically significant
markers
as you can see on the on the left the
missingness increases
the different bucket buckets of
missingness on the x-axis you can see as
the missingness increases
as we have more rare alleles
on the right you can look at the um what
i'm showing you
is sort of the minor allele discardance
um as you can see
uh for the common alleles one percent
are above
um we we have the the cumulative
fraction of markers
um in in that bucket um the the allele
discordance is is very very low
so even with uh for the allele frequency
bins of less than 0.001
um we have more than um eighty percent
uh concordance
another um quality metrics that we look
at is
um duplicate sample concordance um as
part of our
of our analysis plan
we send about five percent of the
samples back to the vendors
without um telling them that they that
these are duplicate samples
so on the left you can see the the
absolute concordance between those
duplicate samples
within the vendors and and across
vendors it's
pretty close to 100 and above 99
and on the right you can look at the
minor allele discordance
again within between vendors and within
vendors the
myeloma discordance rate is is very low
one of the things that we did is that we
compared the
allele frequency of of mvp as a whole
first to the thousand genomes so in this
you can see the different mile early
frequency bins
and the mvp is is a gray bar
and the um the thousand genome ancestry
populations are the different colored
bars
and as you can see um mvp has
a um you know the mvp allele frequency
is spread across across
the entire data set what we have
noticed is that if we split the mvp into
the ancestry
subsets for example the allele frequency
of mvp seems to be
different from the thousand genome
indicating that there is a lot of
diversity in in the mvp population
we also have done a lot of work on
identifying
related individuals and to make sure
that
when the data is used for geos we get
good quality
you know gos analysis results so we have
used
the kinship analysis to to differentiate
between
for example parents offsprings full
siblings and first cousins
and we are also able to pick up
[Music]
duplicates or twins in that process
we have also looked at runs of
homozygosity
um as you know um the
the bottleneck populations should have
longer runs of homo
runs of homozygosity while the admix
population
should have shorter runs and we can see
that the
the range that we have in mvp indicating
that you know we have
um you know populations across the
spectrum
in terms of um admixture
here's what i'm showing you is
the projection pc where we
we projected that the mvp which is in
grey
on to the onto the thousand thousand
genome population with uh pc one and two
on the left
being shown on the left um as you can
see that
um yes mvp does have the the caucasians
and the
yri and and the asian cluster
but there is a a pretty good spread of
mvp samples
between those clusters indicating again
the diversity
that we have in mvp and on the right is
just
another way of showing you the same
thing where grace tell the mvp
um another way of looking at genetic
diversity in the mvp
sample about 70 of the mvp samples are
clustered with the gbr population um for
example
but you can see that there is a large
number of population that cluster with
yri
and other various sort of ad mixed
populations so to speak
so this gives us an ability to have
reasonably large numbers of each of
those subsets of
ancestries which should should really
help us
um in in doing gus's within those
subsets
rather than doing across all the genetic
subs
ancestry subsets so in conclusion
um mvp is is very large we have more
than 800 000
already and we are still uh continuing
to recruit
and as i showed you it is very diverse
cohort and should enable genetic
analysis across stratified populations
meaning that you know even the the
minority populations we should have
enough
in number to be able to do statistically
relevant
uh relevant conclusions from g was
analysis for example
we have very rich and longitudinal
clinical data that is associated
with these samples and which allows us
to do very fine phenotyping
in terms of disease and subsets of
diseases
mvp data in general is of very high
quality
and overall what i want to
as a take home what i want to say is
that you know
mvp cohort will allow us to increase the
scale of non-european populations um
upon which genetic analysis has been
done this should really
allow for building population subsets
specific prs
and even disease-specific prs because
you know
we we have enough number the end should
should allow us to
do meaningful um statistical conclusions
and with that i want to sort of
acknowledge um all the peoples involved
in it
um especially the mvp participants for
their altruistic
donation of samples and their data to
the mvp program
thank you everyone